if there's a crisis in New York City you
know AOC is not too far away and here
she is trying to explain why we need
more care and hand-holding and housing
and help for these people fortunately
the people listening to her weren't
really having it
the first is that there is various
consensus here across geography and
States on increased Federal resources to
cities and municipalities dealing with
this issue the second is to allow for
work authorizations so that the folks in
here can get to work and start
supporting themselves as soon as
possible they are prevented from getting
jobs they are prevented from employment
and that is part of the strain on our
public system the faster that folks can
access the work that they're asking for
legally the better we can solve this
problem
attention of temporary protected status
for Venezuela who are the largest
population
[Music]
I really I already dropped the F-bomb
once I can't even say what I'm thinking
about her like it is just incredible
first off there there is consensus
amongst the people here we should have
more Federal resources oh I'm shocked
Democrat politician there's consensus
that someone should give us more money
if we just had more money we could solve
this problem we don't have enough money
could someone please write us a check
that's one thing maybe she should talk
to zielinski I heard he's doing okay
these days uh then her thing that we
just need a work authorization situation
these people need jobs no they need to
leave you cannot stay here you are
illegal you just wandered in some
douchebag at the border let you in and
he should probably be fired or his boss
should be fired but you gotta go you
can't stay here but this idea that they
need jobs this is the same Dullard
this is the same Dopey dingbat socialist
AOC who when Amazon tried to bring
40 000 jobs to Queens right they were
going to bring it to the New York City
area she fought Amazon because she
doesn't like big companies right she
doesn't like giant corporations so 40
000 jobs that maybe these people could
have got I wouldn't have been for that
it doesn't really make sense but if she
cared about jobs she wouldn't be
fighting corporations that try to bring
jobs in healthcare and everything else
liar buffoon morons
foreign
[Music]